My name is Sherman Alexie and on the
bantamweight champion of the world.
Uh,
no,
I'm a writer,
poet,
short story writer,
novelist,
screenwriter.
You're young bastard.
I'm doing okay.
Uh,
uh,
it is a strange dilemma because in some
sense,
you know,
I was very negative,
very native identified and I still am,
but that's almost become secondary.
I've sort of joined the tribe of highly
established literary writers.
So,
you know,
I'm with Jonathan Franzen's of the
world.
Uh,
you know,
we,
I know I'm a little bit,
but that's sort of my peer group now
rather than this sort of,
you know,
Indian world literary world.
I'm now in this sort of
make believe world of writers who
supposedly hang out a lot,
although none of us ever do.
So I'm in,
I'm in a community of riders,
highly successful literary writer is
now.
Oh,
it's all.
I mean,
I haven't changed anything I've written
based on all that stuff.
So the perceptions of me may have
changed or the my career,
but I'm still writing the same stuff.
It's still pretty much about spokane,
Indian males stumbling through live.
So,
uh,
I think it's because of the combination
of skills I have,
you know,
I work in multigenre is,
um,
you know,
I do stand up comedy.
I helped make movies.
I think all of that has contributed to
it.
I'm not just a novelist or not just a
short story writer.
So I think,
uh,
in this highly technological world with
many diverse and diffuse influences,
I think I'm able to hit a lot of bases.
Nobody who's ever been poor,
whatever,
use the phrase selling out,
uh,
wow.
You know,
you know,
my influences and the genre artists come
from my Indian writing ancestors,
the previous generation when you're
talking James Welch,
Simon Artese,
Scott Momaday,
joy Harjo,
Leslie Silko,
Linda Hogan,
Adrian St Louis,
all of these writers were multigenre.
They all wrote poetry and novels and
short stories and nonfiction and dabbled
in song writing and filmmaking and
documentary making.
So my original influences were native
American multigenre artists.
Uh,
now these days the younger native
writers are not multigenre.
So it's very interesting.
I'm not sure what's happening,
why that has changed,
but I grew up as a kid writer.
Uh,
nobody ever told me I was supposed to be
one thing,
so just because I've happened to become
successful in a number of those genres,
it wasn't because I was pursuing them
economically,
it was because I saw the artistic
possibilities in all of it.
And I was taught that was when I was a
19 year old undergraduate.
Yeah.
I think I'm the least educated Indian
writer out there.
Uh,
yeah,
I've been,
I've taught at the University of
Washington,
so,
but I'm not a good teacher.
So I think that probably disqualifies
me.
Uh,
yeah.
I'm not in academia at all.
Uh,
in terms of a full time career.
I think it's interesting because I think
when you look at native American
literature,
you're going to find that it doesn't
really reflect the diversity of the ways
in which the writers actually live their
lives.
Nobody has ever written,
for instance,
in academic farce,
a native American teacher at college
forest,
which is a time honored and wonderful
genre.
You know,
David Lodge made a whole career out of
it,
writing economic forces.
And I,
you know,
every,
every writer you can name as written it,
but we haven't done it,
uh,
you know,
whereas that novel about that Indian
architect or that Indian lawyer,
uh,
there's a distinct lack of white collar,
native American literature,
despite the fact that most of it's most
visible practitioners are white collar
themselves.
So,
uh,
I think there's an effort,
a somewhat of an insecurity that to
prove your indianness by focusing almost
entirely on our reservation based
identity.
I think it's old fashioned actually,
you know,
I think people think it's something new.
But the idea of being a storyteller,
you know,
for most of our existence was not
related to books.
It was about the ability to stand up in
front of the fire and,
you know,
earn your supper.
Uh,
so I think it's just something old and
inspired in me,
but I never really was the funny guy
growing up.
If you'd asked my siblings,
they tell you I was the depressed guy in
the basement.
But,
uh,
there the funny ones,
but,
uh,
it just,
I got on stage and started talking and
people laughed at the beginning.
I didn't even necessarily know what was
happening,
uh,
but as the years have gone on,
I realized that a humorous,
pretty amazing in its ability to
transcend differences politically,
ethnically,
racially,
geographically,
economically.
Uh,
there's something about it that really
opens people up spiritually,
I think.
And they listen.
They pay attention and it's also a great
way to offend people.
Uh,
I don't know.
We've all been to literary readings,
you know,
where we got theater but so bored by the
person up in front of us reading their
work so dispassionately that it nearly
turns us off their books.
Uh,
you know,
there are writers who I've heard do
their work that I could only hear their
voice when I'm reading their books and
it's so disinterested in their own stuff
and I just never wanted to do that.
Uh,
I wanted to make the mistake the other
way,
you know,
I'm pleased when somebody is offended by
my large stage presence because there's
still people who show up will get
offended.
Uh,
I get up there and give a show and I'm
improvising and,
you know,
talking about current events and what
happened yesterday or what happened an
hour ago,
what happened five minutes before I
walked into the place,
you know,
and giving people a glimpse of how my,
crazy mind works and then they'll come
up after me and said,
well,
I'm really disappointed you didn't read
the story.
And,
and you look at them and think,
well,
you can read this story.
You know,
what happened tonight will only happen
once,
you know,
you were here for one time thing.
Uh,
so I guess people are trapped in their
perceptions of what a literary artist is
supposed to be.
Uh,
you know,
I write poems naturally.
I'm writing them all the time.
I think it's more of a reflex talent
than fiction is for me.
It seems like I have to work harder to
write fiction.
Uh,
that sad poems are much more demanding.
You have fewer words,
you can make fewer mistakes.
And if you write a 10 line poem,
you really can't make any mistakes.
If you do,
the poem is terrible.
You know,
when you write a novel,
you have all that space to mess up in
and people are more forgiving.
So,
uh,
I think poetry audiences are far more
demanding than fiction and audiences are
well,
you know,
writers generally come in two groups,
those who love what they do and those
who can't stand what they do.
Um,
in the second group,
I have a really difficult time looking
back.
Uh,
yeah.
So I figure out of the thousands of
pages I published,
there's probably about 100 great pages.
I think I worked on probably about a two
percent greatness rate.
Uh,
so there's probably 10 poems to stories
that are great and the rest of it is
from anywhere from pretty good to know
total crap,
you know,
the book is not played out.
The idea of what a book can be is not
played out in its form as it is with
paper and covers and um,
and there are things that can be,
that digital will never touch.
And that's one of the things I wanted to
do with this,
uh,
and comparing it to a cassette tape,
the old fashioned way of making a mix
tape,
which,
you know,
I love burning cds too,
but there is something far more
passionate and hands on and hard work
about making a mix tape on a cassette.
A,
it's too easy to revise with a CD.
And today's technology makes it too easy
to,
to change immediately.
You can cover your mistakes quicker.
I,
I think,
uh,
I think it allows you to have this sheen
of perfection around yourself,
uh,
and with,
an old fashioned book or an old
fashioned cassette tape,
you can actually see all the flaws and
imperfections and the bad choices.
Uh,
and I think there's something we lose
with technology when you talk about bad
choices.
They cost $300.
Number one,
I don't think anything that costs $300
can be called the gala perion.
Uh,
you know,
how much of the world can afford a $300
reading device?
A one percent of one percent of one
percent that automatically qualifies for
economically elite status.
Uh,
but what,
what,
what's really going on here,
the reading public doesn't really know
about all they're concerned about and
all their defending is they're reading
convenience,
which I completely understand whether
it's because of physical disability or
because of personal preference or just
the newness of it,
why they love a digital book,
but they don't understand the economic
corporate pressures going on in the
publishing world and what's going to
happen.
And this is going to happen on the
Internet to,
uh,
we like to pretend that the internet is
free.
Uh,
you know,
we like to pretend it's an open source
culture.
But as culture changes,
as corporate,
old corporate models of distributing
information are changing,
you know,
I don't know why people assumed that
corporations aren't going to take over
this medium as well because they can.
And,
and,
uh,
so what's happening in the book world,
the digital books,
is that these ebook companies,
you know,
Amazon,
Barnes and noble,
others that are rising a,
they just don't seek to published books.
They're going to end up seeking the
books to be chosen to be published.
So,
uh,
this economic model,
the way it's set up now is going to
favor a certain kind of book a and
publishers and being economically
motivated companies are only going to be
publishing those kinds of books and the
divide between pop culture,
pop writing and literary writing.
Is this going to increase and increase
and increase and it's gonna make it
harder and harder and harder for first
time writers to get published in any
form whatsoever where they'll get
attention,
who can find you,
uh,
who,
who's gonna find anybody.
Nobody's really risen out of the
Internet to become a major voice.
Uh,
they always end up getting a book
published and then the book makes them a
major voice.
Uh,
but nobody has.
I mean,
uh,
I'm trying to think,
you know,
I'm not Internet averse at all.
I'm doing this,
uh,
I mean I love the Internet,
but the fact is,
is that it's a giant,
giant,
unfiltered library which has the
strength and beauty,
but,
but it's impossible to find people and
you know,
what we end up doing anyways,
I go to about five sites,
uh,
you know,
and I think most people probably do the
same thing.
You create this little small town inside
the Internet and we end up in all these
little tiny separate communities.
Uh,
Joan Jett and interviewed Joan Jett,
she said about the music industry.
She said,
the thing that's missing now is
anticipation.
They said that nobody gets an a big line
outside of tower records anymore waiting
for that new stones album to drop.
And nobody stands in line outside of a
record store waiting to buy the tickets
for the WHO concert.
Uh,
there's a real lack of community on the
internet experience when it comes to art
and you can't tell me and it's not true
that communicating strictly through the
Internet forums community and the way
that being together does a,
you're missing all.
But one sense you don't smell paypal,
you don't really hear them,
you don't see him.
Uh,
and we're animals.
We're creatures of senses and the
Internet deprives you of many of those.
And,
and,
uh,
so,
I,
I know there's new art coming based on
this technology and some of it's
happening and it's exciting and
interesting,
but there's nothing wrong with the old
art and I always worry and you see it
with certain Internet folks,
the way in which they're completely
willing to jettison their past in the
pursuit of something new.
And that's what I'm worried about.
Well,
in order to write about the emotional
state of a character,
I have to get as close as possible to
being in that emotional state.
So I have to get that sad.
I have to get that happy,
that crazed,
that bizarre,
that obsessed,
you know,
whatever one of my characters are going
through,
I have to find my way into it.
Uh,
you know,
it's just,
it's just the way I do it.
There's a story in this book called the
Ballad of Paul nonetheless,
where he becomes so obsessed with pop
music and so obsessed with his ipod and
that he,
he,
you know,
every thought he has,
this can become directly related to a
song.
So I went that far into it.
I,
I tried to talk only in song lyrics.
Uh,
you know,
whenever anybody was talking to me,
I drove my friends and family mad
because whenever they would talk to me,
you know,
I would say,
well,
that reminds me of this,
you know,
a rolling stones song or,
or whenever anybody said something
accidentally that was a lyric or a title
of a song,
I would then sing the song.
So it was crazy.
But it got me seeing the way it was
completely alienating.
My friends and family really got me to a
place where I could write that story
about this really genial guy who's
actually very much an anti hero,
a case of beer a day.
Uh,
you know,
I could drink a fifth of Tequila a day.
Uh,
you know,
it becomes a drinking problem when it
affects your relationships with people,
uh,
when it affects your job or your school,
your grade point average,
uh,
you know,
affects your,
it's a drinking problem when you're
sitting on your couch at home,
drinking a case of beer all by yourself
and then you pass out and grabbed the
fifth of Tequila when you wake up.
So it's pretty obvious what my problem
was.
I wrote the lone ranger and Tonto
fistfight in heaven and the business of
fancy dancing a while drunk and
drinking.
So,
uh,
there's,
there's certainly a lot to be said for
my desperate years.
My Alcoholic Year is my active alcoholic
years as being the source of some pretty
good work,
uh,
for being the source of the two books
that established and made my career.
Uh,
but the thing is,
it's unsustainable.
Uh,
you know,
if you are using substances to feel your
creativity,
uh,
you're going to have a very,
very short artistic life.
You're going to be a sprinter.
And,
and,
uh,
by and large I wanted to become a
marathon runner and I can only run the
marathon if I'm sober.
You Kill Your brain,
uh,
you know,
please try to find me the successful
drug user,
you know,
try to find me the high functioning
alcoholic,
you know,
career person,
and,
and you could probably find in their
work when they were drinking,
when they were a,
I bet you could look at the downfall of
some amazing writers who wrote a one or
two great books and then just fell
apart.
I'm pretty sure that's a related to
alcohol consumption.
So it's unsustainable.
Uh,
you know,
it's sort of like the environment,
uh,
you can only pour so much pollutants
into it before the temperature changes
dramatically.
So I think a drug and alcohol abuse is
like the greenhouse effect for riders.
Well,
I mean,
I'm an alcoholic.
That's,
you know,
my family is filled with alcohol
alcoholics.
My tribe is filled with alcoholics.
The whole race is filled with
alcoholics.
It's a,
for those Indians who try to pretend
it's a stereotype,
they're in deep,
deep denial.
Uh,
it's an everyday part of my life and as
a writer I use that a to write about it,
you know,
partly for fictional purposes and
narrative purposes,
but partly what the social hope that by
writing about it,
maybe it'll help people get sober and it
has,
I've heard from them,
uh,
you know,
the social function of art is very
important to me.
Uh,
it's not just for art's sake.
I have a very specific,
very specific ideas in mind about what
it can do.
I've seen it happen.
So it is writing about alcohol that
helps me stay sober.
Uh,
and I think reading about alcoholism
helps other people stay sober.
I try to meet deadlines
I have,
you know,
more dependence.
Uh,
so it's a very,
very,
uh,
basic triangle needs that bottom part of
the triangle.
But,
uh,
well they're always surprising me.
The kids are,
I surprisingly,
if their insights into the world and of
course because they're my children,
I pay more attention to what they're
saying.
Then pretty much everybody else on the
planet.
I care more what my kids say on a daily
basis.
Then,
you know,
the smartest people on the planet,
and so I listened and their insights are
really surprising and the way in which,
how unfiltered they are and,
and,
uh,
their obsessions and passions,
they don't apologize for any of that.
So I learned a lot from them.
You know,
it's also aggravating and irritating and
exhausting,
uh,
the sacrifices you make and you know,
you know,
sometimes it feels like my whole life as
a to do list.
Uh,
but,
uh,
you know,
I think their passion for life really as
reinspired me.
No I don't,
I mean they're,
they're,
they're autonomous.
I certainly,
if they want to read my stuff and talk
about it later,
that'll be great.
But until then,
uh,
it was so funny though.
I was profiled on the layer news hour
recently and I was watching the rough
cut of it and my son came down,
my eight year old and he was watching it
on the TV with me and it was a five
minute piece about poetry and I read a
couple poems and I read one very
emotional,
one of my father's death and it was over
and my son looked at me.
He's eight years old.
They looked at me.
He goes,
Dad,
you're pretty good.
So that was a great moment.
It's funny.
This popped into my head,
so I'll go with it.
Shoeless Joe Jackson,
uh,
who was banned from baseball in 1919 for
allegedly fixing the world series a
country boy ended up being a great
baseball player,
one of the greatest of all time.
I'd like to talk to them about that
world series about the mysteries of
human nature because,
you know,
you're looking at the stats.
It's,
I'm pretty sure he didn't participate in
the fixed,
but he knew about it.
So I'd like to have the discussion with
morality,
which she will list Joe Jackson.
Well,
there are just certain poems and novels
and stories that resonate forever and
ever,
uh,
you know,
poems.
I always return to Emily Dickinson
because I could not stop for death that
kindly stopped for me.
Uh,
no
theater,
Rhett keys.
I know a woman,
you know,
I knew a woman,
lovely later bones when small birds side
back at them,
James,
right?
Suddenly I realized that if I stepped
outside my body,
I would break into blossom.
So,
uh,
and then,
you know,
I can,
the end of Grapes of Wrath when Rosa,
Sharon breastfeeds,
her child has died,
but she breastfeeds to starving man.
That moment.
Uh,
so it's always individual works.
even in life I don't,
I don't have heroes,
I believe in heroic ideas because the
creators of all those ideas are very
human.
And if you make heroes out of people,
you invariably be disappointed
as her Jack Keats a snowy day.
The book,
you know,
the idea of multicultural literature is
very new.
And so as a little Indian boy growing up
on the reservation,
there was nobody like me in the books.
So you always had to extrapolate.
But when I picked up a snowy day with
that inner city Black Kid,
that child walking through the snow
covered pretty quiet and lonely city.
Oh,
I mean,
when he was making snow angels and you
know,
when he was getting a snowball fights
and when he got home to his mother and
it was cold,
and if you put them in a hot bath tub
and put them to sleep,
the loneliness and the love in that
book.
Oh,
just gorgeous.
So that picture book resonates with me
still.